you
[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
Narula first up another medical use for
an active agree D ingredient in
marijuana a study published this week in
the New England Journal of Medicine
showed that the use of cannabidiol which
is derived from marijuana was successful
in decreasing seizures in children who
suffer from a complex epilepsy disorder
John took a look
when Desmond Phillips had his first
epileptic seizure he was just eight
months old rouille and corinne phillips
are his parents he's not able to breathe
and then it stopped for a moment and it
started again just one after that the
seizures never really stopped sometimes
20 in a week in 2011 at its worst more
than 2,700 it really affects quality of
life you don't really have much no
quality of life you know under those
circumstances what's that like for you
as parents we didn't really have a lot
of hope when he was undergoing so many
seizures hey you
one after another anti-seizure
medications failed in 2014 doctors at
NYU Langone Medical Center put Desmond
on cannabidiol or CBD one of the
compounds in the marijuana plant CBD
does not induce a high this week's study
of 120 children with a rare form of
epilepsy found those who were given CBD
along with their standard medications
had a nearly 40% reduction in the
frequency of seizures we just didn't
know with the placebo response wisdom
dr. Oren divinsky directs the NYU
comprehensive epilepsy center at NYU
Langone and led the trial after so much
time literally 4000 years of anecdote
and belief
we now have scientific rigor we have
evidence
Desmond is now nine and can go days
without a seizure sometimes weeks I just
had the best mother's day ever outside
on a gorgeous day without having to
worry about this having a seizure you
ready to go home
he's like the best hugger I mean he
gives you these big hugs
ready amazing results amazing the best
mother's day ever yeah I mean what what
if it's been transformative for the
family I spoke to the company that makes
the medication they said that the
application to the FDA is in progress
right now it should be in very shortly
and of course this is evidence it's
evidence-based medicine which is what
everybody's been calling for in terms of
medical marijuana its uses to not go on
anecdotal evidence but a trial now
you've got it
fascinating